what is your profession so i am a
mechanical design engineer and i design
tanks of various types not
tanks not like tanks like that like like
the puke hat like not the not water
tanks or or fuel tanks but like like a
sherman yes with like tracks and they
and so we have what are you talking ab
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute you design military grade tanks
so some are military and then some are
uh commercial so the commercial the
commercial commercial wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute okay first of all
uh i i'm fascinated by tanks uh i am a
military history buff
uh i actually have a favorite tank from
history what is that i don't know if you
do
mine is the uh russian t-34 okay nice
that i like that tank because
that tank really saved russia and kicked
the nazis asses and they never saw that
tank coming they had contempt for the
soviet union they thought we're just
going to roll in there
and uh these people are beneath us
and we have our cool german tiger tanks
and suddenly uh the russians
show up with this amazing tank that's
technologically very simple
but
just wouldn't break down
and uh and the german shells couldn't
pierce it so i think the t-34 is one of
the most heroic tanks in history yeah i
think it's it helps save the world well
there's something definitely to be said
for simplicity i mean it's the
the pinnacle of design is not when
you know what's left to add but it's
what it what can you take away when
there's nothing left to take away then
you've hit it there are famous stories
of that the soviet uh crews that the
russian crews that had to work the t-34
there was a giant uh stick like an iron
stick you know an iron shaft that was
pretty much what made it go forward
backwards sideways and it was so hard to
maneuver
that the the the guy and the crew that
maneuvered it had a giant wooden mallet
and would just bash it to the left
bash it to the right bash it forward
bash it backwards and that is how they
operate the tank but it worked the thing
wouldn't break down well i'll have to uh
take that for inspiration because that
sounds pretty foolproof yeah yeah yeah
please uh check out
and this is i'm gonna do a quick ad for
the russian t-34 tank
uh helped uh defeat the uh the nazi
invasion in uh in 1942 41 42 and turned
the tide of world war ii in my opinion
get yours today